bonsoir bienvenue très heureuse de vous
retrouver dans savau regarde ce soir
éloge de l'écoute avec la patronne de
Radio France bonsoir Syb veale bonsoir
et merci d'être notre grand témoin ce
soir au commencement était l'écoute
c'est votre premier essai aux éditions
de
l'Observatoire l'écoute comme antidote à
la fureur des réseaux sociaux et au
règne des écrans on va en parler
longuement tout à l'heure vous réagirez
également au baromètre annuel sur la
confiance des médias baromètre de nos
confrères Lacroix paru aujourd'hui notre
grand débat ce soir a-t-on les moyens de
bien vieillir dans notre pays
l'assemblée a repris cette semaine
l'examen de la proposition de loi de la
majorité sur le sujet est-elle à la
hauteur des enjeux du vieillissement de
la population le défi démographique est
immense mais où sont les moyens nous en
débattons dans un instant sur ce plateau
avec mes invités enfin ns affranchis ce
soir le parti prix politique de Carole
Bargeon le regard européen de Richard
verli et puis Bourbon Express l'histoire
du jour à l'Assemblée signée Stéphanie
des piierr voilà pour le menu on y va CB
ça vous regarde c'est
[Musique]
parti c'est un sujet qui mériterait
mieux qu'un débat Parlement terme de foi
avorté comment une société doit
s'adapter au grand âge qu'est-ce que
signifie bien vieillir dans notre pays
alors on est près de 2 ans après le
scandale Orpa après un début de lecture
interrompu en avril et revoici donc la
proposition de loi de la majorité sur le
sujet et c'est vous qui en êtes la
rapporteur bonsoir Laurence Cristol
bonsoir et merci d'être là vous êtes
député renissence de l'héros vous
retrouvez votre collègue de l'opposition
Jérôme Gedge avec qui vous débattez ce
soir et qui ne quitte pas l'hémicycle
depuis le début de la semaine député
socialiste de lessones spécialiste de
ces de ces questions du grand âge
bonsoir Édouard pronud bonsoir bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes directeur
d'établissement pour personnes âgées
correspondant régional ADPA association
des directeurs des services pour
personnes âgées enfin bonsoir Raphaël
Martin bienvenue directrice du pôle
accueil de jour et accompagnement des
aidans ce sont souvent les les familles
au sein de l'association Delta s vous
accompagnez notamment les familles qui
ont décidé d'éberger chez elles leur
leurs parents dépendants on en parlera
apparemment sont de plus en plus
nombreuses depuis le le covid sibil Veil
c'est un sujet qui nous concerne tous je
n'oublie pas que dans une vie antérieure
vous étiez conseillère technique à la
solidarité en 2007 alors n'hésitez pas
si vous souhaitez interroger nos invités
on commence par planter le décor comme
chaque soir qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans ce
projet de loi c'est le chrono de Bacco
qu'on accueille tout de
suite bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Miriam
bonsoir à toutes et tous alors je vous
invite à vous retourner pour la
chronique de Stéphan blackakovski cette
loi rien ni à vous myiam ni aux autres
gouverner c'est prévoir or si le
gouvernement est régulièrement confronté
à des situations imprévisibles il y a au
moins un domaine où on est tout à fait
capable de prévoir l'avenir c'est la
démographie on sait qu'en 2030 il y aura
30 % de Français qui onont plus de 60
ans et donc nécessairement ça entraîne
le fait que le nombre de personnes âgées
dépendantes est amené à augmenter à
l'avenir donc évidemment le le président
Macron est bien conscient du problème
regardez il avait déjà promis une loi
pour financer la dépendance du grand âge
en 2019 bon cette promesse il n'a pas pu
la tenir mais Celine tienne 2 ans plus
tard il renouvelle la promesse en
parlant à nouveau de ce projet de loi
sur le grand âge et puis la loi passe de
nouveau aux ubiliettes ça c'était le
premier quinena mais pour se faire
réélire Emmanuel Macron avait notamment
s'était engagé à recruter 50000
infirmiers surtout des AES soignantes
d'ailleurs pendant 5 ans donc ça vaut
dire dire 10000 par an et pour cette
première année 2023 seulement 3000
postes ont été créés donc on s'interroge
commentit-il qu'un problème aussi
clairement identifié et aussi important
ne soit pas la priorité donc la question
est posée par les aalamé à Aurore berger
j'essaie de comprendre comment un sujet
aussi brûlant passe en dessous de la
pile si si on est un peu lucide il est
passé un peu en dessous de la pile de
beaucoup de gens y compris même
médiatiquement je pense qu'il y a une
forme de peut-être de dénis je sais pas
peut-être de dénis individuel face à
notre propre vieillissement de dénis
collectif parce que c'est extrêmement
violent et brutal de voir vieillir ce
qu'on aime de voir vieillir ses proches
et donc finalement on l'a assez peu
traité alors cela dit les choses
commencent à bouger puisque vous le
disiez on examine cette semaine à
l'Assemblée une proposition de la
majorité sur le Bien Vieillir donc le
texte comprend d'assez nombreuses
mesures notamment sur pour lutter contre
la maltraitance et l'isolement des
personnes âgées donc pour la
maltraitance par exemple un dispositif
va être mis en place de manière à faire
mieux monter plus rapidement les alertes
ou les signalements pour ce qui est de
l'isolement il y a la création de deux
nouveaux organismes donc une conférence
nationale de l'autonomie ça c'est pour
évaluer la situation et puis par
ailleurs un autre organisme donc le
Centre national de preuve de prévention
de la perte d'autonomie et de ressources
gérontologiques et ça c'est pour pointer
les innovations essayer de trouver des
innovations alors je veux pas du tout
présager de l'efficacité de ces desux
organismes mais ça donne le sentiment
d'une réponse un peu technocratique
alors que on sait bien que le problème
de c'est de trouver un financement le
gouvernement a commandé un rapport en
2019 qui disait il faudra 10 milliards
de plus d'ici 2030 ce qui fait que quand
Aurore berger cette semaine dit le
gouvernement apporte 100 millions
supplémentaires pour les auxiliaires de
vie François Ruffin sort sa calculette
et dit le compte n'y'est pas on l'écoute
vous pouvez pas dire 100 millions comme
ça en insistant sur millions en disant
que c'est une vraie avancée en disant
que c'est un signale très fort 100
millions 500000 auxiliaires de vie ég
200 € ég moins de 20 € par mois 16 € par
mois à peu près voilà ce que vous
proposez aujourd'hui bref ce que tout le
monde attend c'est donc cette fameuse
loi de programmation promise depuis si
longtemps pour sur plusieurs années pour
se donner enfin les moyens d'affronter
la question de l'indépendance des
personnes âgées bonne nouvelle aurore
berger c'est elle a promis que cette loi
de programmation et bien elle serait
votée en tout cas examiné l'année
prochaine alors bon il y a eu tant de
promesse que forcément on reste un peu
prudent mais si vous avez des solutions
des bonnes idées faut en parler ce soir
alors on commence avec vous Laurence
Cristol déjà sur le
calendrier ça a été reporté ça a été
aborté on y est mais en fait le gros du
gros c'est encore dans un an avec cette
loi grand âge qu'est-ce que vous dites à
tous les professionnels qui vous disent
tout ça est insuffisant attendez encore
non pas du tout non non nous dès le
début du mandat on a été plusieurs
députés de la majorité à s'investir dans
ce projet de loi et cette proposition de
loi et je suis très heureuse aujourd'hui
parce qu'en fait on a eu des avancées
significatives certes au printemps
lorsque nous l'avions déposé nous avions
beaucoup de d'opposition et beaucoup de
remarques sur le fait qu'elle n'était
pas à la hauteur au point que votre
collègue de la majorité hein c'était
madame imora à l'époque claque la porte
et dit j'arrête j'arrête le job c'est
pas la hauteur aujourd'hui cette
proposition de loi qui faisait 14
articles on fait 49 on a accepté et on a
mis en avant beaucoup d'amendements de
tout bord que ce soit du gouvernement de
notre groupe parlementaire mais
également des oppositions on se retrouve
avec un projet une proposition de loi
qui comprend trois grands axes donc la
prévention de la perte d'autonomie afin
de pouvoir anticiper justement sur cette
transition démographique dont vous
parliez et qui est que aujourd'hui nous
devons nous préparer à avoir une société
de demain qui sera différente de celle
d'aujourd'hui avec plus de personnes de
65 ans et plus que de moins de 15 ans
mais c'est tout un transition
démographique oui c'est sûr on n'est pas
du tout que sur les épades hein
aujourd'hui c'est 700000 personnes et et
et on est près de 20 millions he de
personnes de plus de 60 ans dans le pays
totalement c'est un c'est c'est une
préoccupation sociétale deuxièmement la
maltraitance effectivement après le
scandale norp la deuxième partie
comprend effectivement tout un volet sur
la prévention la lutte contre la
maltraitance et le troisième le virage
domiciliaire c'estàdire ouvrir des
perspectives justement à une avancée en
âge avec un choix domiciliaire qui nous
soit propre donc pour ça il faut aussi
du P personnel des auxiliaires de vie
des des aides à domicile alors vous vous
avez beaucoup bataillé vous êtes un
député d' médiatique Jérôme GED et on
vous entend beaucoup sur le sujet c'est
quand même pas rien ça y est enfin c'est
peut-être un peu tard mais enfin le
gouvernement s'engage c'est une victoire
pour vous moi je il s'engage pour 2024
avec des financements à l' je ne boute
pas mon plaisir en entendant la première
ministre cet après-midi fixer enfin un
calendrier 2024 alors en même temps chat
et Chaudé craint l'eau froide Christophe
blovski a rappelé 2019 2021 Édouard
Philippe disait j'aime beaucoup Édouard
Philippe mais là il disait c'est le ce
sera le grand marqueur social du quinena
bon tout ça c'est fracassé bien sûr il y
a eu la crise covid mais c'est toujours
les vieux ça passe toujours derrière et
pour être tout à fait objectif cette
malédiction
procrastinace et bien c'est pas propre à
Emmanuel Macron ces deux présidents
prédécesseurs avaient aussi promis des
réformes sauf que Ben plus on avance
plus les baby boomers parce que c'est
deux dont on parle arrivent aux â des
fragilités alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a de
bien déjà dans cette proposition alors
attendez parce qu'en fait vous voyez là
il y a plusieurs Bries qui se mettent en
place pareil mes collègues députés
Renaissance qui en avaiit à peu près
autant marre que moi de ne pas voir
venir les choses décident de déposer une
proposition de loi une proposition de
loi ça peut pas appréhender tous les
sujets c'est les règles de la 5e
République donc il y a des articles
sympathiques utiles qui vont dans le bon
sens mais qui ne répondent pas au défis
princip principaux les défis principaux
c'est les moyens pour avir avoir plus de
personnel humain pour accompagner dans
les épades mais aussi dans les services
à domicile des moyens pour baisser le
reste à charge des familles ce qui est
payé dans les maisons de retraite mais
au-delà de la question de la dépendance
des moyens pour adapter la société au
vieillissement parce que vous voyez la
transition démographique je reprends
cette expression c'est comme la
transition écologique il y a des gens
qui pensent que c'est pas un problème
vous vous rappelez Jacques chira qui
disait la maison brûle et on regarde
ailleurs bah moi aujourd'hui avec
d'autres je dis la maison vieillit et on
regarde ailleurs alors que c'est
totalement prévisible et ça suppose
d'adapter plein de politiques
les logements les transports la place
des personnes agées dans les Médi
justement il y a eu ce qu'on appelle une
une comment ça s'appelle ça une une
stratégie interministérielle consacré au
Bien Vieillir attendez aménagement des
logements accessibilité des gares des
enceintes sportive accès à la culture ça
va dans le bon sens je vous dis un mot
voyez j'applaudis la loi pour 2024 je
trouve que ça va dans le bon sens cette
PPL cette proposition de loi la
stratégie qui a présenté Aurore vendredi
dernier c'est une opération de
communication qui met des Bullet point
on va on va adapter les logements on va
ouvrir les épades sur leur extérieur
mais une stratégie ça suppose des fiches
opérationnelles des moyens et cetera
donc la vraie stratégie ce sera la loi
de programmation grand âge pour cela
pour cela il faudra traiter la question
qui fâche qui d'abord il y a deux
questions qui sont importantes d'abord
écouter la place des personnes âgées
elles-mêmes on peut pas définir une
politique voyez ce weekend il y avait un
truc c'était le contrealon des vieux
organisé par le Conseil national
autoproclamé de la vieillesse c'est les
68 ararts pour faire simple voilà autour
d'Aran nouchkin des boomers qui ont dit
nous on est la on est la génération qui
a révolutionné le regard de la société
sur la jeunesse voilà c'était mais 68 et
on se rend compte qu'en fait on va avoir
besoin de révolutionner le regard de la
société sur la vieillesse on veut pas
être mis dans un coin on veut pas être
invisibilisé on veut que notre parole
compte leur slogan c'est rien sans les
vieux pour les vieux donc ça c'est le
premier enjeu et puis le deuxième et
bien il faut dégager des finan ça a été
très bien dit tout à l'heure et ça c'est
un choix de société il faut qu'il ait
lieu c'est pour ça qu'en préparant la
loi faut qu'on ait une conférence du
financement c'est affreusement techno
mais où est-ce qu'on prend est-ce qu'on
augmente les impôts attendez vous parlez
beaucoup là on va on va y venir on va y
venir on sait que vous êtes habité par
le sujet où où on trouve l'argent on
connaît l'ampleur de nos déficits
Édouard pr vous travaillez dans lespad
donc il APA on a tout ça en mémoire la
maltraitance la lutte contre la
maltraitance c'est un un des objectifs
de de ce texte qu'est qu qui s'est passé
tiens depuis 2 ans on a parlé de
contrôle du gouvernement plus plus
nombreux est-ce que vous les avez vu sur
le terrain est-ce que vous avez mieux
rémunéré vos personnels aussi pour
éviter la difficulté au quotidien de
voir partir ces gens-là les deux à la
fois à la fois effectivement mieux
rémunérer le personnel avec tout ce qui
est de l'ordre du segéur mais qui n'est
pas équitablement réparti à la fois sur
le privé et le public les comment dire
les fonds qui ont été versés pour le
personnel il faut qu'il soit vraiment à
l'ensemble du secteur aussi puisque ça
nous fait entre guillemets en mettant en
nous mettant en concurrence déloyale et
quand on voit effectivement le déf
démographique é pénalisé voilà après
dans le cadre du voilà de
l'établissement public que que je dirige
et dont voilà la dépa représente c'est
vrai que la maltraitance depuis 2 ans et
demi euh bah en tant que directeur on a
toujours en tête cette ce cette
thématique là voilà il faut en tant que
directeur il faut pouvoir savoir que en
tant qu'institution on fait
mécaniquement de la
maltraitanceè les biscottes les REP
inspide est-ce que tout ça c'est c'est
fini bah oui mais c'est ce qu'on disait
he quand on on lisait le livre de
christop je parle d'Orp oui oui voilà
c'est ça c'est c'est peut-être que le
secteur a été injustement versé avec
tous ces excès qui ont dû être dénoncé
et justement qui devait être dénoncé
après maintenant voilà les repas tout ce
qui est protection c'est vrai qu'on y
accorde beaucoup d'importance pour le le
bien-être de la personne c'est c'est
évident et les contrôlesô oui alors
effectivement il y en a pour
l'île-de-fance la région où le où je
suis correspondant régional la
directrice de Laars a déclaré en 2 ans
l'ensemble des contrôles seront faits
euh plusieurs collègues effectivement me
me disent soit contrôle sur pièce ou
soit il se rendre sur les épades mais on
sent bien que voilà en face il faut nous
mettre également les les moyens de de
pouir on va en parler tout de suite des
moyens puisque c'est le nerf de la gueur
dans ce dans ce sujet dans ce dossier je
voulais qu'on dise quand même un petit
mot à vous avant de vous donner la
parole Raphaël Martin sur le changement
sociétal tiens que vous appelez de V vux
le regard sur les vieux qui changent
c'est un reportage qui a été tourné à
Douet dans une structure qui propose une
sorte de colocation pour personnes âgées
regardez ce que ça donne on en parle
juste
après et alors
quand les mamies font de la colocation
le jeu de société c'est une affaire
sérieuse on peut le mettre comme ça et
oui c'est parfait il faut qu'on fasse
bien attention quand même pour se
détendre un peu quand il y a pas trop de
temps on joue au Dada aux
chevaux Nicole Josian et Janina vivent
ensemble dans cette grande demeure de
Douet sous l'œil attentif de
la responsable de maison j'ai appris
qu'hier soir vous vous étiez couché tard
bon c'était un beau film apparemment
céit un beau film vous avez le droit de
faire ce que vous souhaitez si tous les
soirs vous voulez veiller vous avez le
droit et vous préférez regarder la
tision en bas ou dans votre chambre
alors
en bas en bas
pourquoi on n pas ê seul pour ne pas
être seul ouais par qu'en bas le soir on
point une tisane on discute on refait le
monde quand c'est rien la télé on
parle Dolores s trois auxiliaires de vie
se relent ici pour assurer une présence
permanente et organiser les activités
les colocataires partagent le salon la
cuisine et le jardin mais je trouve
qu'on est bien ici vous vous sentez chez
vous
oui on peut discuter ensemble tout ça on
dispute
pas aux étages chacun sa
chambres en de la maison nous ouvre les
portes de son petit royaume ma
table une lampe pour m'éclairer pour
lire une petite Bouloire pour faire ma
tisane le soir là c'est pour le petit
bébé oui oui pour mon arrière petite
fille mais surtout beaucoup d'amour pour
toujours ah c'est beau à l'abri des
regards dans sa chambre Janina aime
aussi s'adonner à sa grande passion de
toujours le tiercer bon il s'affiche
d'une louable régularité mais moi je
regarde la fin il garde son mot à dire
alors qu'est-ce que je ve mettre un
point
d'interrogation la maison de Janina et
ses complices compte 10 chambres il
reste donc de la place et pourquoi pas
pour un
homme Raphaël Martin on voit que ça peut
être une solution mais en discutant avec
Clément per le reporter qui s'est qui
s'est rendu à Douet pour pour tourner
dans dans cette dans cette structure il
explique que le rest à charge si on
enlève toutes les aides s'élève à plus
de 2000 € par mois il faut se le
permettre tout le me n pas les moyens de
se le permettre et puis en plus quand on
perd en autonomie dans ce type de
résidence il y a des frais
supplémentaires pour être aidé au
quotidien donc c'est une solution mais
c'est pas non plus la solution sur les
aides cont trêitement vous vous vous
accompagnez les les
aidanss est-ce que c'est simple de
savoir à quoi ont droit les personnes
aujourd'hui alors c'est un vrai parcours
du combattant ça c'est sûr les aid ont
besoin d'être informé d'être orienté sur
tous les dispositifs existants euh donc
ça on a la chance en France d'avoir
quand même pas mal pas mal d'aidees
financièr qui existe encore faut-il y
avoir droit encore faut-il oser les
demander aussi parce que beaucoup ne les
demandent pas par ignorance de leur
existence et puis ensuite ces aides ne
couvrent malheureusement pas tout toutes
les dépenses les dépenses qui augmentent
et donc il y a encore des choses à faire
à ce à ce niveau-là si bien que
certaines familles décident de garder ou
de d'accueillir plutôt chez elles
exactement de de de personnes âgées
est-ce que est-ce que c'est un phénomène
que vous voyez oui alors c'est pas un
phénomène nouveau parce qu'il y a déjà
tout d'abord une dimension culturelle
qui peut être très importante chez
certains aidents qui n'imaginent pas
confier leurs proches et qui qui se font
un devoir entre guillemets de
l'accueillir chez eux parce que voilà
c'est leurs parents donc ils veulent
aussi leur rendre ce qu'ils ont ce
qu'ils ont pu recevoir quand ils étaient
plus jeunes ensuite pendant le covid on
a constaté que beaucoup d'aidents soit
s'installer chez leurs proches soit
accueiller leurs proches chez eux et
cette enfin ce cela s'est amplifié avec
le la possibilité de télétravail ce qui
fait qu'auourd'hui aujour'hui beaucoup
d' dents continuent de travailler
conciliie vie professionnelle et rôle
des dents grâce au télétravail mais ça
implique une organisation ah oui non
mais c'est zéro répi parce que souvent
c'est des personnes souvent des femmes
d'ailleurs j'ai vu un reportage qui ont
à leur charge leurs ados hein leurs
grands ados et leurs parents ou le un
parent cette fameuse génération sandwich
exactement et effectivement il y a zéro
répis puisqu'on a plus son espace à soi
on accueille son proche chez soi donc on
a plus son espace où déposer ses
émotions on a plus son espace où pouvoir
souffler un peu et puis faut avoir et
puis il faut avoir l'espace
effectivement nous on accompagne plus de
1300 éedans par an et j'ai en tête des
témoignages des dents qui se sont qui
ont pris leurs parents chez eux alors
qu'il vaient dans un studio donc en plus
vous rajoutez l'intervention
d'auxiliaire de vie d'infirmière à
domicile ça devient extrêmement
compliqué extrêmement anxiogène une
parfois une cocotte minute enfin les
dentes qu'on accompagnait nonfin avait
vraiment besoin de son sas de
décompression auprès de nos
professionnels dans d'autres situations
ce sont des parents qui ont on laissé
leur chambrees pour pouvoir pour que les
enfants continuent leur leur scolarité
qui ne peuvent plus parfois travailler à
plein temps alors ça unere question
parce qu'effectivement il existe des des
congés de prochet dents mais qui sont
encore limités dans le temps et qui sont
insuffisamment rémunérés pour beaucoup
des dents et donc il y a et ces
solutions pour bien comprendre c'est
plus économique même si c'est un peu
cynique comme question mais ça compte
que que les pas c'est sûr que
l'économique à son à son mot à dire
là-dedans ça c'est sûr la société elle
prend un peu le relais de d'un grand
manque de de moyens est-ce que c'est
c'est bien ce ce genre de de solutions
là est-ce qu'il faut les mettagnement
des personnes âgées il y aura
immanquablement les solidarités
familiales et fort heureusement mais
elles ont besoin d'être prolongé
amplifié par la solidarité nationale
pour la simple raison c'est quand vous
avez une personne en perte d'autonomie
avec un besoin d'accompagnement
médicalisé qui soit à domicile ou en
établissement là pour le coup il faut
des professionnels on va jamais demander
aux aidants familiaux de faire un change
de faire une une de poser une perfusion
et cetera donc Solidar familiale oui
elles ont leur importance mais il faut
pas oublier qu'il y a aussi des
personnes âgées qui n'ont pas ou qui
n'ont plus de famille mais il faudra la
solidarité nationale et c'est ça le
grand défi c'est de voir comment ce
risque de la perte d'autonomie on
l'intègre dans ce à quoi les Français
sont très attachés qu est la logique de
la sécurité sociale à chacun selon ses
moyens en fonction de ses de ses besoins
et on na pas encore tout à fait franchi
et et le refus d'obstacle de tous les
gouvernement c'est évidemment que ça va
nécessiter de mobiliser des des
financements et pour ça faut qu' un
rapport de for on y va sur les
financements mais peut-être une petite
intervention sur sur le regard est-ce
qu'il change vous le voyez changer vous
sur les vieux ou pas nous on le voit
changer et surtout le terme
d'invisibilisation je crois qu'il était
très intéressant là tout à l'heure dans
le reportage on voyait ces femmes on
entendait leurs voix et c'est des voix
qu'on entend trop peu et ça c'est
quelque chose qui est important on a
fait une consultation lors de la
dernière élection présidentielle qui
s'appelait ma France avec France Bleue
sur les préoccupations des Français et
alors que tous les médias traitaent des
sujets de sécurité euh divers d'économie
le sujet qui était remonté en premier et
qui s'est amplifié au moment évidemment
où il y a eu le scandale d'orpa ça a été
le l'aide et les personnes âgées comment
est-ce que on dans une famille on les
porte la problématique des aidents et
des aînés donc c'est un sujet qui est
très peu traité mais qui en réalité
c'est une préoccupation qu'on voit
beaucoup monter et qu'il faut leur
donner la parole faut les faire
connaître les faire voir et on a fait
une collection de podcast qui s'appelle
essentiel et qui a donné la parole
notamment une auxiliaire de de santé
c'est des voix qu'on entend très peu et
quand on entend en fait la difficulté de
leur métier c'est assez rare de
l'entendre s'appelle essentiel et cette
femme racontait la difficulté ils ont
très peu de temps ils ont pas le temps
d'écouter d'être à l'écoute de ces
personneslà donc ils font que des soins
très rapide vous disiez tout à l'heure
he hor cétait cach allez-y parce que je
trouve elle a dit quelque chose
d'ailleurs qui était très fort elle
disait en fait on a 16 toilettes à faire
on a très peu de temps et en fait la
seule chose qu'on fait c'est VMC est-ce
que vous savez ce que c'est VMC c'est
visage maincu c'estàd qu'on a pas le
temps de faire plus donc quand on a le
temps de faire que ça on n pas le temps
de prêter de l'attention à la personne
et je pense que ça c'est l'un des défis
alors on est au cœur du sujet on y va
Laurent chistol il y a un énorme
problème d'aide à domicile il y a en
manque de bras aussi bien d'ailleurs
dans dans les épades que en ambulatoire
dans les chez les chez les personnes les
auxiliaires de vie plus personne ne veut
faire ce travail là mal rémunéré peu
reconnu beaucoup de transport qu'est-
qu'on
fait déjà moi ce qui m'a beaucoup
interpellé dans dans votre dans votre
prise de parole c'est effectivement ce
regarde de la société qu'on a sur sur
l'avancée en âge et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui tous les métiers autour de
la personne âgée sont en souffrance en
souffrance parce que ce sont c'est pas
c'est une question financière on est
bien d'accord Jérôme on a et on a grâce
à la première ministre et à auroard
berger cette loi de programmation qui
arrive donc on va donner les 10
milliards à trouver hein d'ici 2030 oui
mais il faut fa que toute la société
change son regard tout à l'heure on
parlait des bbomer oui c'est c'est c'est
c'est ces hommes et ces femmes
aujourd'hui ce sont ceux qui ont vécu
mes 68 dans leur tête moi moi qui suis
médecin quand je leur parle à mes
patients je ne regarde jamais leur âge
chronologique c'est leur âge
physiologique qui m'intéresse c'estut
dire aujourd'hui le regard de la société
doit changer je pense que ce ce congrès
là ce weekend a pu peut-être faire
avancer les choses et la façon dont vous
en parlez aussi est effectivement
importante parce que ce que vous dites
sur la VMC c'est terrifiant moi je l'ai
vu le visage maincu je le répète pour
ceux qui prennent l'anten 17 mars le 17
mars c'est la première journée des aides
à domicile et moi j'avais reçu à ma
permanence les associations et les aides
à domicile et elles ont exprimé toutes
leur inquiétude toutes leur difficultés
al il y a eu déjà beaucoup de
propositions François Ruffin et Monsieur
Bonel qui est de la majorité brunoel ont
travaillé sur le sujet ce sont des
horaires fractionnés comment on fait
est-ce que on on rémunère le trajet
est-ce qu'on fait un statut comment on
fait pour que enfin ce métier là soit
valorisé et pour qu'on on arrive à à
embaucher tout simplement à rendre
attractif ce ce travaill là jérô Gad
hier sur un autre plateau télé mon ami
Luc brousier a eu cette jolie formule il
a dit dans ce pays tant queune
influenceuse qui vit à Dubaï sera plus
reconnue et valorisée qu'une aide
soignante à monondemarsan la société
tournera à l'envers voilà ces métiers
c'est les premières lignes c'est des
c'est des vrais métiers d'utilité
utilité sociale or vous l'avez dit leur
statut les conditions de travail ne sont
pas adapté enfin c'est le moyen-âge
notamment parce que c'est un des rares
métiers pour lequel il y a une
tarification à l'heure qui subsiste donc
moi je me félicite que on commence à
mettre un gros coup de canive dans ce
principe pour les salariés à temps plein
pour leur dire que vous allez berger
donc veut expérimenter dans les
département pilote une tarificationation
la dotation globale ou la dotation
forfaitaire c'estàd qu'on est plus sur
une tarification à l'heure ce qui fait
que elle est même surveillée à la minute
quand une aide à domicile arrive euh
pour faire il peut m y avoir des
interventions de 15 ou de 30 minutes il
y a pas de lien social dans ces
conditions il y a pas le temps voilà la
personne âgée c'est le temps de la
lenteur c'est le temps de l'écoute c'est
le temps de l'empathie et si vous êtes
minuté parce que vous avez de la
télégestion un système où vous arrivez
vous décrocher le téléphone vous faites
un numéro pour dire je suis arrivé à
12h43 et vous et quand vous repartez
vous faites la même chose on marche sur
la tête on industrialise ce qui est de
la pâte humaine et ce qui est du lien du
lien direct voilà donc ça il faut il
faut renverser la table mais encore une
fois tout ça ne pourra pas se faire à
moyen constant je je veux pas à nouveau
tendre la perche mais c'est c'est le le
choix de société qu'on doit organiser
pour se dire et bien les postes qui sont
à créer leur reconnaissance le bien avec
la ministre r berger c'est qu'elle dit
cette loi grandagege c'est la société
qui va la faire on va la coconstruire
avec les parlementaires les les
représentants de la nation mais aussi
avec les personnes âgées elles-même avec
les professionnels qu'est-ce que vous
vous attendez et quelles ressources vous
pourriez trouver puisque c'est ça
qu'il faut trouver aujourd'hui c'est des
moyens en tout cas moi je confirme
effectivement vous évoquiez la la
souffrance des personnels vous évoqueiez
ce weekend un congrès sur Paris il y en
avait un même lundi mardi dans leséros à
Montpellier la DPA effectivement il
était évoquer les mêmes choses la
souffrance à tous les niveaux et y
compris les personnels de direction que
je représente ici qui doit payer pour
cette grande réforme là est-ce que ce
sont les retraités les personne ALG
elle-même ou est-ce que c'est toute la
nation la solidarité c'est un choix de
société et on est bien d'accord qu'il y
a quelque chose de ationnelle làdedans
il y a quelque chose de prendre soin des
plus faibles des plus fragiles des
personnes âgées il y a quelque chose qui
doit êre effectivement peut-être décider
ensemble mais ça ne veut pas évacuer
également le problème du financement ça
c'est certain il y a il y a quelque
chose à voir là-dedans en tant que
professionnel par contre c'est peut-être
une simplification c'est vrai que voilà
ma dernière réunion au niveau régional
beaucoup de personnes beaucoup de
directeurs du domicile était présent et
je les sentais au bout un peu à bout
bout du R un peu ça un peu ça ou ou là
je sais pas si la loi du Bien Vieillir
va vraiment répondre aux objectifs ou en
tout cas les objectifs très concrets
qu'ils ont et la complexité entre
effectivement du tarif horaire du
forfait du tarif à l'acte peut-être une
simplification très certaine serait
heureuse au niveau de l' on Demand qui a
pu inventer un tel système que vous
décriviez à la minute Laurence chistol
il y a pas mal de propositions parce que
il a il a déjà Jérôme G comme il a
beaucoup parlé je vais prendre ses
propositions vous nous dites si c'est
possible augmenter la fiscalité sur les
grosses successions limiter les
auxéations patronales euh accordées aux
personnes âgées qui emploient une
personne à domicile diviser par deux
l'actuel crédit d'impôt employeur vous
dites quoi ce sont des bonnes pistes ou
pas mais toutes les pistes sont
intéressantes le problème n'est pas là
on va faire justement une loi qui va
mettre tout le monde autour de la table
vous venez de le dire à l'instant euh on
peut pas nous seuls parlementaires
décider on a des pistes qu'il faudra euh
mais lesquels sont les vôtres moi
aujourd'hui je veux que tout le monde
soit sous la table sur la table pour
pour vraiment décider c'est un problème
sociétal ce que je disais en en préu en
préambule aujourd'hui c'est vraiment ça
concerne tout un chacun je pense que
toute la nation doit prendre part au
fait que nous avançons en âge et que
nous devons avoir une solidarité entre
les générations je voudrais revenir sur
ce que vous avez dit il y a quelques
minutes sur le fait que on et vous
l'avez également exprimé madame que les
les personnes étaient perdues les
aidants familiaux les personnes âgées
aujourd'hui dans cette proposition de
loi nous instaurons un guichet unique ce
fameux guichet unique qui va permettre
par département d'avoir un lieu unique
où on pourra se renseigner avoir les
pistes qui permettront de pouvoir
prendre en charge notre personne euh
notre nos parents et pouvoir aussi avoir
une coordination des actions nous avons
aussi la prévention de la perte
d'autonomie parce que ça c'est important
aujourd'hui euh je pense vraiment qu'on
est à un tournant de notre société 90 %
euh des des personnes interrogées
veulent rester à leur domicile veulent
rester autonome et en France aujourd'hui
on a un problème c'est que nous avançons
en âge mais nous gardons pas notre
autonomie nous avons pas une qualité de
vie qui est au rendez-vous et nous
sommes un pays dans lequel il y a
énormément de de de travail à faire donc
c'est la prévention de la perte
d'autonomie afin de pouvoir proposer à
tout un chacun à vous à moi demain de
pouvoir faire notre propre choix nous
sommes autonomes nous avons un parcours
domiciliaire nous avons besoin d'aide
nous avons des épales qui seront
différents qui seront plus médicalisés
ça aussi ça ça peut répondre à une
problématique compris bien compris mais
là on a tous rendez-vous quelque part
dans les mois qui viennent parce que le
l' l'enjeu de société est fondamental
Raphaël Martin qu'est-ce que vous
attendez des pouvoirs publics
concrètement à l'heure de la grande
consultation et des arbitrages déjà qui
remettent qui remettent la lumière sur
la beauté du métier parce que en enfin
je constate he mes équipes sont
extrêmement engagées extrêmement
impliquées elles ont beaucoup souffert
avec le confinement avec tout le battage
médiatique même si on est que des
centres d'accueil de jour en tant
qu'institution on a ai ici été assez
ébranlé don c'est un métier qui a du
sens qui est effectivement source de
frustration et de souffrance pour bah
pour nous professionnels parce que on
sait tout ce qui existe sur le papier
quand on parle aux aidans beaucoup d'ans
nous disent mais sur le terrain on
narrive pas à faire appel à des
infirmières à des à des aides à domicile
et cetera mais voilà c'est vraiment
voilà mettre les moyens sur la table
pour que derrière les aidents ne soient
plus obligé de de faire le change tout à
l'heure monsieur GCH parlait il y a des
aents qui sont obligés de changer leurs
parents de changer la protection de
leurs proches parce qu'il y a plus
d'infirmière au domicile j Gad le mot de
la fin vous avez des propositions vous
avez réfléchi depuis longtemps le levier
fiscal mais est-ce que vous pourriez
voter ensemble cette F moi j'ai j'ai
toujours considéré que ça pouvait être
un sujet transpartisan parce que euh
tout le monde est concerné après le
choix de société sur les sur les besoins
auquel il faut répondre d'ailleurs pour
alimenter le débat il y a quelques mois
moi j'ai écrit ma loi grand âge idéal
elle est mise au pot commun et on peut
l'amander après le choix d'organisation
du partage des richesses des des crédits
qu'on mobilise là en effet ce sont des
choix politiques je suis content on a un
cadre dans lequel on va vooir ses choix
mais on peut avoir des gros désaccords
par exemple une des propositions c'est
est-ce qu'il faut de nouveau un jour
férier voilà qu'on ferait travailler
comme ça avait été é fait après la
canicule de 2003 bon c'est une
proposition sur la
tablejet débat je moi je préfère qu'on
augmente les droits de succession sur
les plus hautes successions voilà je
pense que c'est une mesure de solidarité
qui permet de dégager des moyens donc il
y a encore un vraiage droite gauche sur
cette question la dépendance on s'arrête
là on va l'avir ce débat il ne fait que
commencer je vous remercie beaucoup
d'être venu sur ce plateau vous restez
avec moi sibil veille dans une dizaine
de minutes les parti pris de nos
affranchis ce soir réveillez-vous Carole
Bargeon revient sur l'injonction
présidentielle au chefs d'entrepr prise
face au chômage qui redémarre comment
Georgia Meloni sous-traite les migrants
en Albanie ce sera le billet européen de
de Richard verni et puis ce soir de de
quoi nous parlez-vous Stéphanie
Despierre dans Bourbon express de
députés qui parineent des otages du
Hamas à tout à l'heure les amis mais
d'abord on va plonger dans votre livre
sibyil veille au commencement était
l'écoute aux éditions de l'Observatoire
c'est un essai stimulant vous disséquz
ce que vous nommez la société du
défouloir sans garde-fous ni pudeur dans
dans laquelle les réseaux sociaux nous
ont plongé revenir à l'écoute regardez
c'est dans l'invitation d'éèine Bonduel
et on en parle toutes les deux juste
après si on vous invite sibil veille
c'est parce que chacun fait le constat
qu'il est de plus en plus difficile
d'échanger sans violence en particulier
sur les réseaux sociaux assiner
insultter menacer sont la règle écouter
et comprendre
l'exception cette du défouloir sib ve
présidente directrice générale de Radio
France depuis 2018 vous l'a décortiqué
dans votre essa au commencement était
l'écoute que ce soit la mécanique à l'
sur les réseaux sociaux que ce soit les
algorithmes de ces grandes plateformes
il conduisent inexorablement à ce que
chacun soit dans son couloir de nage et
pire encore qu'il soit dans son bassin
et que dans ce bassin dans lequel il est
ce qui circule le plus ce sont les
contenus qui font le buz les contenus
les plus trashes à traversos expérience
personnelle et professionnelle vous
diagnostiquez cette société du défouloir
en janvier dernier cela vous vaudra
d'ailleurs un échange salé avec Cyril
Hanouna animateur sur la chaîne C8 suite
à l'un de vos tweets l'animateur s'en
prend publiquement à vous dans son
émission mon visage est affiché en gros
plan derrière l'animateur qui exhibe mon
prétendu salaire je me sens un peu comme
ces bandits dont la tête est mise à prix
dans les western mon tort avoir relevé
sur la virulence de sa charge sans
nuance contre l'audiovisuel public dans
l'émission de la veille un débat public
dégradé mais face à cela quel remède
face à la colère l'indignation vous
faites une ode à l'écoute la radio comme
antidote et pour cela il faut embarquer
la jeunesse une jeunesse trop souvent
confrontée aux
écrans tu partage pas trop le même
esthétisme que tes amis personne
sere en 5 ans la maison ronde a
développé 2500 podcast jeunesse une
façon de lutter aussi contre l'écran à
toutouva ce doudou des temps moderne
comme vous l'appelez sibil veille vous
érigez vos stations en modèle de
l'écoute mais Radio France n'est pas
exempte des dérapages comme la mauvaise
blague de Guillaume Maurice qui n'a pas
vraiment plu à vos auditeurs alors en ce
moment il y a le déguisement netania qui
marche pas mal pour faire peur vous
voyez qui c'est c'est une sorte de naz
mais sans prépusce voilà alors puisque
personne n'est à l'abri
siveille nous avons une question comment
Radio France peut-elle se prémunir de
l'air du
clash réponse siib veille alors vous
avez là montré une polémique
effectivement qui a démarré il y a 3
semaines c'est l'exception par rapport à
tout ce qui se passe sur nos antennes
d'ailleurs c'est une polémique quelque
part qui reflète quelque chose que j'ai
voulu montrer dans le livre qu'on vit de
polémique qui montent sur les réseaux
qui sont ensuite développés et qui
contamine les médias qui retomb dans les
réseaux donc en fait au lieu de traiter
de sujet de fond comme celui qu'on a vu
ce soir on est dans l'aair des
polémiques et sur Radio France les
différentes antennes que soit France
interre France Info FRANCE bleue France
Musique on essaie au contraire de
rentrer dans les sujets de fond et de
pas suivre les polémiques du jour ça
vous êtes déçu c'est quoi c'est un
dérapage vous l'avez sanctionné
Guillaume mauris a reçu un avertissement
d'ailleurs il été entendu en audition
libre aujourd'hui par par la la la
justice ça ça vous a choqué ça vous a
ébranlé o au
fond on peut rire de tout mais pas avec
n'importe qui je suis déjà beaucoup
exprimé dessus hêtement ça fait 3
semaines voilà la polémique est derrière
nous honnêtement on essaie plutôt de de
tourner la page il faut savoir que
Guillaume Maurice et d'autres personnes
de l'émission On reçoivent des menaces
de mort ce qui montre à quel point il y
a une disproportion c'est la phrase d'un
humoriste dans une émission d'humour
c'est pas un journal c'est pas un
activité qui soit un politique c'est
c'est vraiment une phrase d'humour qui a
déclenché une polémique des menaces de
mort à tel point qu'aujourd'hui mon rôle
htement c'est plutôt de protéger l'quip
de le protéger et de protéger Charline
vonencker et et l'équipe on va revenir à
votre constat avant d'arriver au au
solution parce que c'est aussi un livre
optimiste l'écoute victime de la société
du défouloir est-ce qu'on en est
vraiment là aujourd'hui est-ce que notre
société est à ce point polarisé que plus
personne ne
s'entend alors vraiment dans ce livre
j'essaie d'apporter un antidote à
quelque chose qu'on ressent tous et je
pense qu'on ressent tous une sorte de
grande fatigue face à ce brois permanent
ou que ce soit sur les réseaux sur
certains plateaux de télévision dans la
rue dans les violences qu'on peut voir
dans certaines arènes médiatiques ou
politiques cette voilà ce ce ce que j'ai
essaie de nommer socié du défouloir
c'est quelque chose qui s'incarne par
des paroles de plus en plus virulente on
écoute que ceux qui crient plus fort on
entend des injures à la fois pour des
vrais sujets mais aussi pour du sujets
beaucoup plus dérisoire c'est
l'indignation permanente c'est que tous
les jours il y a une cause nouvelle sur
laquelle on s'indigne sur sur les
réseaux sociaux des réseaux sur lesquel
chis un camp et l'affrontement faut
choisir un camp et pourquoi pourquoi
parce que derrière il y a un
fonctionnement de ces réseaux-là les
fameux algorithmes qui nous enferment
dans un entre soi algor qui nous
enferment mais qui surtout conduisent à
valoriser les propos les plus
extrémistes ce qui plusieurs actions
donc les plus extrêmes qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire pour vous très concrètement
savoir écouter l'autre je vous pose la
question à vous parce que vous en parlez
dans le livre vous êtes fille de
psychologue vous avez grandi dans dans
une atmosphère particulièrement propice
à ça a créé le lien par l'écoute al vous
rappelez effectivement ma mère était
psychologue je pense que ça m'a
accompagné dans une grande partie de mon
enfance de ma vie puisque je j'entendais
parler de ces gens qui vont voir
quelqu'un pour être écouté donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a des gens qui ont le
sentiment de pas tout pouvoir tout dire
ou qui ne sonentent pas suffisamment
écouté et c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose qui voilà qui que dans mon mode de
management j'essaie de porter j'en parle
Liv ça s prend ça s'enseigne l'écoute ah
je pense que c'est déjà ce qu'il y a de
plus républicain parce que tout le monde
a la capacité d'écouter donc c'est ce
qu'il a de plus égalitaire euh et
contrairement à l'art oratoire dans
lequel il faut comprendre les codes il
faut savoir parler et l'apprendre je
pense que l'écoute ça se développe très
facilement et qu'il faut davantage
valoriser les gens qui écoutent et ça
moi je fais dans mon mode de management
parce que ce sont des gens qui créent du
lien là où ceux qui parlent beaucoup
c'est quoi sont sont moins dans le lien
avec les autres c'est intéressant cette
question du management par l'écoute on
pense au pays du Nord aux pays
scandidats femmes d'ailleurs hein qui
ont pu diriger ces pays c'est quoi
lesécoup de trampoline alors l'écoup de
trampoline c'est une expression que je
cite dans mon livre c'est ce moment vous
avez une discussion avec quelqu'un un
peu comme on peut avoir là toutes les
deux où je rebondis sur votre phrase
pour pouvoir la compléter et quelqu par
l'échange qu'on a en s'écoutant l'une et
l'autre fait que on est plus créative et
qu'on va arriver progressivement à finer
une solution moi j'ai le souvenir de
réunions avec mes équipes et je pense
que tous ceux qui travaillent avec des
équipes vivent ça de réunion oùah il y a
une sorte de créativité qui se développe
parce qu'on est ensemble qu'on bondit
les uns sur les autres et justement en
le faisant et ben on va plus loin il y a
des grandes idées que j'ai misise
enœuvre ces dernières années qui ont été
lié à des séances comme ça où on
discutait et etmage cette discussion une
sorte de créativité collective c'est un
sujet aussi très intime pour vous et ça
aussi vous en parlez parce que vous avez
eu peur à un moment pas n'importe lequel
le covid de ne plus entendre çatait une
expérience assez dure pour
moi très jeune j'avais déjà eu des
problèmes euh de d'oreill interne
d'oreilles j'avais été opérée pour ça
étant très jeune ENF j'avais oui j'avais
7 ans et au moment du covid j'ai une
variante qui en fait a touché mon
oreille interne c'est le variant Delta
qui a touché mon oreille interne et je
me souviens j'ai eu peur de ne plus
entendre et je me suis dit diriger une
grande maison de Radio qui est un média
d'écoute et je suis d'autant plus
heureuse d'tre que justement c'est un
média qui porte cette valeur là comment
je vais faire si jamais je n'entends
plus je je me vois encore donner cette
phrase là dire ça à mon mari et ça
m'avait ça m'avait saisi et ces
momentslà c'est ceux dans lesquels on se
rend compte à quel point luoui l'écoute
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
fondamental qui nous construit qui fait
qu'on est ce qu'on est aujourd'hui bien
alors les principaux responsable du
basculement dans cette société du
défouloir ce sont les réseaux sociaux
vous citez Pascal Bruckner dans le sacre
des pantoufles l'homme à Faller dans sa
cage sensorielle sentiment d'impunité
qui règne absolument les algorithmes on
en a parler vous pourriez être tout à
fait contre d'ailleurs et marquer les
esprits dans ce livre en disant il faut
fermer x d'Elon musk il faut il faut
faire quelque chose de très fort parce
que la démocratie est en danger c'est
pas ce que vous dites vous n'allez pas
jusque là vous dites la modération avant
tout mais pas euh on va dire la
suppression
alors déjà vous citez Pascal brner
pourquoi j'en parle parce que je pense
que dans ce grand Brouis il y a beaucoup
de gens qui sont fatigués et que la
tentation qui peut c'est la tentation du
repli sur soi donc DEP plus de fermer la
formation de de s'extraire de ce grand
brois de ces polémiques permanentes et
ça c'est quelque chose moi qui me fait
peur parce que je pense que ce jour-là
on ne fait plus société si les gens ne
s'intéressent plus à la vie en société
collective se replie sur eux parce
qu'elle devient trop dur mais est-ce que
vous trouvez que les bénéfices
aujourd'hui des réseaux sociaux sont
toujours plus importants que leur dérive
ou leur danger alors je raconte une
anecdote dans le livre pour en parler je
rappelle un compte que tout le monde
connaît qui est le compte de Pinocchio à
un moment donné on voit ce ce jeune
pentin qui va dans l'île au plaisir qui
est un endroit où tous les excès sont
permis on peut fumer on mange on joue on
fait ce qu'on veut et qu'est-ce qu'il y
apprend que l'excès ne permet pas de
conduire à la liberté mais au contraire
à servi et ce que je vois aujourd'hui
dans les réseaux sociaux pour moi c'est
une sorte d'il au plaisir pour adulte où
on se retrouve confronté on pense qu'on
a la liberté de parler et c'est un peu
la promesse de rég la liberté d'exprimer
ses opinions ses idées de de revendiquer
des choses encore une fois de s'indigner
et en fait on voit à quel point
aujourd'hui ça a servi parce que les
algorithmes ne mettent en avant que ce
qui est excessif ce qui est le plus
extrame il faudra prendre des mesure
drastique un jour ou vous pensez que la
régulation la modération sera suffisante
moi moi je c'est pas que je pas c'est
que je pense que il y a des mesures qui
sont prises par contre je vois une chose
plus en Europe qu'aux États-Unis d' plus
en Europe qu'aux États-Unis et jeis
chose c'est que depuis qu'éon musk a
repris Twitter qui est devenu x ça
change à une vitesse qui est
considérable et ça devient de plus en
plus toxique nous en tant que médiat de
service moi je me pose régulièrement la
question jusqu'à quand on va pouvoir
rester dessus et pourquoi est-ce qu'on y
reste ah oui pourquoi on y reste pour
une seule raison c'est que aujourd'hui
c'est un réseau dans lequel il y a
encore beaucoup de personnes qui le
suivent il est très prescripteur
d'ailleurs la preuve c'est qu'on en
parle he serait pas important on n
parlerait pas il est très prescripteur
ce qui veut dire que pour beaucoup de
personnes il s'informe sur les réseaux
on parlait des aînés il y a beaucoup de
personnes mais il est pas éternel s'il
avait une alternative vous iriez bien
sûr bien sûr mais aujourd'hui temps que
les gens sont dessus il faut qu'on y
apporte de la lutte contre les fausses
informations la lutte contre la
manipulation les le nombre de fausses
informations de manipulation qu'on voit
sur ces réseaux là mais c'est c'est
terrible le baromètre annuel on a
commencé à en parler à partir de de la
fatigue informationnelle c'est la croix
qui fait ce ce travail chaque année la
confiance dans les médias et c'est c'est
vrai qu' il y a une forme de de
contradiction parce que d'un côté les
Français massivement à plus de 70 %
suivent l'actualité avec grand intérêt
on voit les résultats s'afficher et en
même temps ils ressentent pour moitié
d'entre eux une très grande fatigue ou
une forme de rejet par rapport à
l'information soit parce que les sujets
se répète l'Ukraine le covid soit parce
qu'il est ils s'en sont angoissés vous
voyez un paradoxe au contraire une forme
de cohérence alors je pense que c'est un
paradoxe sur lequel il faut que les
médias tr
c'està dire qu'en effet vous vos
chiffres montrent les chiffres qui ont
été présentés aujourd'hui montrent bien
que les Français ont de l'intérêt pour
l'information mais que c'est la manière
dont elle est traité qui pose problème
et si on prend un peu de recul dans
l'histoire en fait il y a eu beaucoup de
moments où on a eu des tensions il y les
années 30 avec des grandes tensions les
années 60 avec le périle nucléaire dans
les années 90 on a connu les Balcans
donc c'est pas la nature de l'activité
qui conduit à avoir ce sentiment de de
fatigue de par rapport à l'actualité en
fait qu'est-ce qui conduit à ça c'est la
manière dont aujourd'hui elle existe où
on se sent bombardé de tas de contenu où
on sait qu'il y a des faususses
informations parce que les Français sont
pas DUP ils savent que sur les réseaux
il y a des choses qui sont fausses ils
ont pas forcément aujourd'hui tous les
outils pour pouvoir les détecter et je
pense que l'écoute quelque part c'est
aussi une manière je rappelle que de de
de les détecter en justement essayant
d'entendre des points de vues
contradictoires et considérablement plus
important en radio quel qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs sur Radio France que on va
dire sur les chaînes d' information
continue ou même sur les réseaux sociaux
pour terminer un tout petit mot sur la
musique on cultive les valeurs d'écoute
la musique dont vous écrivez qu'on ne
soupçonne pas toujours la puissance sur
nos corps elle a une place la musique
dans votre vie elle peut changer la vie
parce que c'est ça aussi l'écoute je
pense que la musique c'est un moment de
partage d'émotion on a tous des
souvenirs de concerts où il y a une
musique qui nous transporte et on sent
qu'en fait on partage cette émotion là
avec le tous ceux qui sont autour de
nous et c'est ça qui est absolument ve
dans la musique c'est c'est quelque
chose qui transmet une émotion qui est
la même et qui est partagée quel que
soit la sociologie quel que soit
l'origine nationale moment raconter
d'ailleurs dans le Liv c'est des études
qui qui montrent ça et c'est des moments
de grandes émotion de grandes
communication et pour moi ça montre
encore une fois que ce qu'on écoute ça
développe aussi un imaginaire ça
développe aussi une capacité à imaginer
les choses à aller plus loin et c'est
une des grandes vertus de ce que
l'écoute apporte merci beaucoup sibil Ve
au commencement était c'est l'écoute
c'est allire aux éditions de
l'Observatoire c'est é rudit mais des
références aussiclectique corelsan ou
Angèle en passant par plus tar qui vous
a inspiré votre titre vous restez avec
moi c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur partie prix il vont
vous faire réagir on les accueille tout
de
suite on termine comme chaque soir avec
les parties prix ce soir signé Carole
Bargeon de l'OPS et Richard Verly du
quotidien suisse blique installez-vous
les amis on démarre par Bourbon Express
l'histoire du jour à la Assemblée
nationale c'est vous Stéphanie des
pierres qui nous l' raconé bonsoir
Stéphanie bonsoir c'est l'histoire de
députés qui parenent des otages détenus
par le Hamas séance photo cet après-midi
dans les jardins de l'Assemblée
nationale avec une cinquantaine de
députés à l'initiative de Caroline yadan
parlementaire Renaissance très engagé
dans le soutien aux Israéliens depuis
l'attaque barbare du 7 octobre alors
chacun d'eux avait en main un portrait
d'une des personnes kidnappé avec ses
affiches au bandeau rougge qu'on a vu
placarder en Israël mais aussi dans les
rues des des grandes villes françaises
alors sur les 240 autagees encore détenu
par le Hamas il y a des adultes des
enfants et même des bébés plusieurs
nationalités il y aurait au moins h
français alors ces députés dont certains
sont allés en Israël depuis le drame
voulaient se mobiliser le maître mot de
cette opération c'est il faut libérer
les otages et surtout on ne les oublie
pas jusqu'à la libération du dernier
saint et sauf moi j'ai Parigné quelqu'un
qui était tout simplement dans la
rêveptie qui était dans le désert alors
je sais qu'il y a des gens qui n'aiment
pas que des jeunes s'amusent mais de là
aller massacrer des jeunes qui font ça
ça me rappelle légèrement ce qui s'est
passé au niveau du Bataclan euh le le
droit de jeune à je dirais s'exprimer
par le P de la musique tout simplement
ne semble pas être du goût d'un certain
nombre de personnes il faudra toujours
le dénoncer voilà Stéphanie ce
parrainage d'otage intervient alors
qu'un accord aurait été trouvé je n'ose
dire a été trouvé euh pour pour libérer
une une cinquantaine d'entre eux alors
cette initiative de parrainage était en
fait en préparation depuis plusieurs
jours parmi les participants une
majorité de députés du camp présidentiel
mais aussi quelques élus les
républicains et des non inscrits
beaucoup appartiennent au groupe
d'amitié franceisraël alors sur la photo
il n'y a pas de députés de gauche mais
il y a quelques élus socialistes qui ont
donné leur parrainage et pour les autres
parlementaires et bien certains
n'étaient pas au courant et d'autres
n'étaient pas
conviés est-ce que vous aviez proposé à
tous les députés de tous les groupes
politiques de par en otage non on avait
pas proposé ni au rassemblement national
ni à la France insoumise le
rassemblement national parce que on a
fait le choix depuis le début de ne pas
travailler avec eux et on ne souhaite en
aucun cas travailler avec eux et puis la
France insoumise parce que je crois que
quand on est incapable de qualifier de
terroristes des gens qui emmènent un
bébé de 9 mois en otage loin de ses
parents je pense qu'on est totalement
disqualifié pour participer à cette
opération alors des sénateurs et mais
aussi des députés européens sont engagés
dans en ce parrainage qui concerne
environ 250 élus alors il s'engage à
communiquer le plus souvent possible sur
le sort des otages certains vont
contacter les familles d'autres déjà ont
été contactés par les familles d'otage
en espérant que l'accord dont on parlait
débouche vraiment rapidement sur la
libération des otages merci beaucoup
Stéphanie des piierre ses empathies
sélectives sibyil veille on en a
beaucoup parlé on a c'est un peu la
continuité de votre Liv on narrive pas
finalement à avir l'empathie pour pour
les deux camps aujourd'hui en tout cas
ça c'est un des sujets émotionnels très
fort et c'est vrai qu'il y a des
situations très humaines dans lesquelles
sortir des postures écouter ceux qui
pensent pas comme vous pour partager des
valeurs humaines et humanistes je pense
que c'est important et l'écoute amène à
ça aussi entendre des gens qui pensent
pas comme vous Carole bargean c'est à
vous réveillez-vous à lancer Emmanuel
Macron pas vous vous êtes tout très en
forme ce soir mais c'est le président
qui a dit ça hier soir devant des des
chefs d'entreprise qu'a voulu-t-il dire
euh et bien il s'exprimait hier à
l'Élysée devant un parterre de chef
d'entreprise qui étit réunis euh pour
soutenir les PME et Emmanuel Macron en a
profité pour signifier que le temps de
l'effort pour les patrons comme pour les
salariés est devant nous et pas derrière
euh d'autant qu'il estime lui évidemment
avoir fait des efforts euh et il ne
s'est pas privé de rappeler que il avait
réussi à réduire significativ le chômage
contribuer à augmenter le la CR le
nombre de créations d'emploi qui est
l'une de ses promesses phes depuis
2017 mais cette apostrophe ou plutôt
cette
injonction témoignait aussi d'un grand
énervement de sa part ah bon pourquoi il
était énervé et bien parce que se
réveillez-vous qui pas agressif mais
enfin voilà c'est véhément euh visait
d'abord le MDEF qui est coupable selon
lui d'avoir décidé avec les syndicats de
revaloriser les retraites
complémentaires agic agir pardon Arco de
4,9 %. alors que l'exécutif y était
opposé et qu'il voulait au contraire
ponctionner les réserves de cette caisse
pour financer un dispositif de
solidarité en faveur des petites
pensions cet accord a donc été vécu par
Emmanuel Macron pour qui il n'est plus
temps je cite de redistribuer et de
revenir en arrière comme un véritable
affron euh avec ce réveillez-vous le
président voulait aussi parler d'autres
choses que de politique internationale
et du Proche Orient d'autres choses que
de la violence qui s'exprime partout en
France là on vient de on vient d'en
parler avec Le Meur du jeune Thomas et
alors que forcément le sentiment
d'insécurité des Français sa croit la
d'après la plupart des sondages avec ce
coup de gueule le président voulait
enfin attirer l'attention sur l'économie
montrer qu'il demeurera un réformateur
jusqu'à la fin de son quinquena et que
les efforts pour parvenir au plein
emploi en 2027 et réduire la dépense
publique sont toujours nécessaires bon
c'est bonne guerre on connaît l'état de
nos finances publiques évidemment compte
tenu de l'ampleur de la dette de la
France et des déficits il y a évidemment
urgence à remettre de l'ordre dans les
finances publiques ce que réclame du
reste Bery accord et Acri mais attention
au boomerang l'injon de Macron pourrait
se retourner contre lui car il s'agit de
remettre l'économie au
centre mais il faudrait qu'il y ait une
trajectoire lisible pour tous se
réveillez-vous visant partie les chefs
d'entreprise qui sont enjoints à
augmenter les salaires et c'est heureux
en cette période d'inf il parlait aussi
à lui-même selon vous et il faudrait que
il y ait une trajectoire plus lisible or
un jour on nous dit que c'est la fin de
l'abondance le lendemain on distrib
début l'échec bref Emmanuel Macron prend
le risque qu'on lui rétorque vous aussi
pour nous fixer enfin un cap clair
réveillez-vous monsieur le Président
merci beaucoup Carole et pardon de vous
avoir sucré la chute je vous voyais
venir merci beaucoup alors il vous reste
allz un peu moins de de 3 minutes
Richard pour nous dire le projet de
Georgia melony soustraiter ces migrants
Itali enfin qui sont en Italie en
Albanie et vous nous dites attention il
faut pas caricaturer ça mérite mieux
qu'un rejet de principe absolument alors
d'abord ce n'est pas un projet c'est un
accord que le gouvernement donc de
droite dure de Georgia Meloni a conclu
avec le gouvernement albanais ce sont
deux centres de personnes déplacées que
l'Italie s'est engagé à construire le
premier dans un port shengjin et le
deuxième sur un ancien aéroport dans la
ville voisine de gjader alors l'objectif
c'est d'y transférer dès leur arrivée
sur la sur les côtes italiennes des
milliers de migrants en attente d'examen
de leur demande d'asile ces
installations elles seront construites
par les autorités italiennes gérées par
ell avec onimagine une main d'œuvre
locale albanaise pour tous les services
indispensables le ravitaillement la
maintenance ous l'ordre public alors
d'emblé l'idée peut choquer avec cet
accord il est évident que Rome cherche
bien sûr à se débarrasser des nouveaux
migrants vous savez que Joh jamenoni
c'était un thème récurrent de sa
campagne mais regardons bien les choses
en face et là je vais faire une petite
liste de cinq points premier point
l'Albanie est un pays candidat à l'Union
européenne depuis 2014 et demandeur
d'aide et de forme deuxièmement son
gouvernement est démocratiquement élu
troisièmement ces centres gérés par
l'Italie permettront aux Albanais à la
fois de partager le fardeau migratoire
européen et sans doute d'intégrer de
manière anticipée l'agence de gestion de
l'asile de l'Union enfin 4ème point
est-il plus inacceptable de transférer
ces personnes en Albanie ou bien dans
les rues de les laisser à la portée des
mafias et enfin cinquièmement doit-on
oublier que de toute façon le mot
d'ordre européen c'est celui de la
bnquérisation du continent derrière des
murs de barbelé et l'accélération du
renvoi des étrangers déboutés bref si on
applique ces CIN critères l'Albanie peut
être une solution ah oui la
mouhubitative de de Carole en ditlon non
allez est-ce que ça veut dire pour vous
que c'est la même chose que voulez faire
le Royaume Uni avec le le Rwanda qui a
dû renoncer hein britannique alors
absolument pas première différence le
Rwanda n'est pas sur le continent
européen et il sera donc beaucoup plus
compliqué d'y inspecter des centres de
migrants dans un pays de surcroix non
démocratique et très sourcilleux de sa
souveraineté sur lequel les Européens
ont très peu sinon pas du tout
d'influence deuxième différence l'option
albanaise aux portes de l'Union
européenne peut être élargi demain à
d'autres pays des Balcans occidentaux en
attente d'adhésion voire peut-être à la
Moldavie ou à l'Ukraine bien évidemment
après la guerre ces pays veulent entrer
dans l'UE ils y parviendront c'est
logique c'est normal et bien qu'ils
épaulent les 27 et soient aidés pour le
faire ça a du sens alors enfin parlons
de ce qui fâche c'est les inévitables
retours forcés dans les pays d'origine
ou de transit et bien posons-nous la
question est-ce que le faire à partir de
l'Albanie je vous ai dit que ce sera
dans un ancien aéroport l'un des centres
et bien ça ne permettrait pas de
diminuer l'intensité de ce débat
particulièrement explosif bref face au
drame de la migration l'option albanaise
elle doit être étudiée mais sûrement pas
rejeté voilà un parti prix merci
beaucoup la
coopération européenne avec les futurs
advion de l'Albanie ABS merci beaucoup
merci Richard merci Carole merci
Stéphanie et merci à vous civil ve
d'être passé sur le plateau de la Chaîne
parlementaire au commencement était
l'écoute c'est-à-dire donc aux éditions
de l'Observatoire pour en finir avec la
société du défouloir c'est la fin de
cette émission merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi pour la voir ou la revoir il y a
la chaîne Youtube d' LCP bien sûr très
belle soirée à
[Musique]
demain